okay
okay oh wait it's going no touches
[Music]
can you bring representer up
[Music]
[Music]
good okay
[Music]
are you full-screening
[Music]
looks
[Music]
thanks man you're the man
[Music]
gonna have to do this from the side here
[Music]
look at that what
[Music]
good
just in case okay
[Music]
rock and roll thanks man
jesus christ jesus hello thank you for
saving
us from chad yes save us again
all right this is how it's gonna have to
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
right here
[Music]
here
[Music]
interference
so steven's shot
so
[Music]
uh
all right uh hit record stephen's in in
range okay
do i double check my shots
yeah you can look in here oh yeah put
the nd on yeah make it look better
stand up there real quick
so
i don't know
okay thank you yeah it's still i got it
down a little bit lower to like f9
it's pretty bright though i had it at
five earlier
and also the iso was at like 800 so
well for daylight yeah you don't want it
up that high one is low
okay yep so you can just adjust it from
there
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
wow
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
emily
[Music]
actually i could probably bump your uh
what's your shutter speed at
uh
[Music]
all right
i'm
i know
right
[Music]
hello
[Music]
it may take a few days
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
check one two
one two
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yes
sound good
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
black
[Music]
foreign
is
shoes
shoes
[Music]
soccer
[Music]
foreign
crazy
bye
oh
exclusive numbers
[Music]
that's an interesting twist
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
this
huh
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
one
oh
[Music]
we're leaving
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
19 after a number of their residents
have been diagnosed with the virus
it happened only after the facility
accepted two dozen overpositive patients
from area hospitals a decision that
baffled residents
and their loved ones the decision filed
an executive order by the governor
from the beginning the governor was
allowing covet positive patients to be
placed in the same nursing home as
proven negative patients but many of the
legislators disagreed and went to work
to try and change the policy
cross-contamination between patients and
health care providers
is a significant risk the bill
introduced wednesday would make it
illegal
to knowingly house anyone with the virus
in nursing homes
and it has bipartisan support both
lawmakers brought up the horrifying
abuse of one of these so-called hubs in
detroit
where twenty-year-old jaden hayden
brutally beat his elderly roommate a
resident of westwood nursing home
hayden was living there temporarily
after being diagnosed with the
coronavirus
but the governor now has vetoed it
governor witnessed the standing by our
policy
placing covert positive patience
[Music]
nursing homes to bring in covet patients
to infect those that weren't infected to
kill those loved ones
[Applause]
i love this thing
[Applause]
[Music]
for keeping us all safe today
[Music]
and one thing i want to uh reiterate i
know i've talked about this online
please
everyone here whether you're here in
agreement or protest
we ask that you leave this place cleaner
than you found it be safe
respectful
[Music]
all right so some of the things i'm
about to talk with you about today might
sound repetitive i know a lot of you may
know this information
unfortunately a lot of americans don't
i think that michigan should be the most
wonderful state in the union
uh i believe it can be
and unfortunately it's been brought to
its knees
through systemic policy uh that we've
also been misled about
can i take a second by the way i wasn't
planning this this morning but the
president obviously you've just heard
diagnosed with covid we could take like
five seconds just to say prayer for the
guy
lord we pray for president trump his
family for a swift recovery that uh
he'd be one of those people with lighter
symptoms he'd come through this and you
know what we also pray
for governor whitmer even though we may
not agree with everything that she says
does uh pray for more involved safe
swift recovery and for the recovery of
our nation
speaking of people who trespass against
us
now i was born in michigan
i was born in michigan uh i was raised
in canada a lot of my life sorry
my wife this is the reason i'm here
today my wife was raised in michigan
when i got married and chose a place to
settle down for six years we lived in
grand rapids michigan
[Music]
uh her parents were raised in michigan
my parents
were raised in michigan my grandparents
were born and raised in michigan
and my wife's grandparents were born and
raised in michigan as a matter of fact
my grandfather-in-law
fred he not only was a bombardier in
world war ii he was a professor
at a michigan college and he was a mayor
city supervisor
of bloomfield township
and uh we lost him uh
not that long ago but he is survived by
his
wonderful wife my grandma ruth who i
think we can bring up here this is my
grandma ruth that is
a week ago two days before her 97th
birthday
and as you can see she's out and about
telling kovid to go fornicate herself
with a wire brush
[Applause]
unfortunately for my grandma she is spry
she's with it
but was recently a victim of attempted
murder
by this woman uh governor gretchen
whitmer
all right okay i figured that one would
go over well so
something that i want to be clear about
as we move through today this is not
really in my wheelhouse it's not what i
do this isn't really a show hopefully it
arms
all of you with information and we can
demand information from
your elected officials and hopefully the
rest of the country will pay attention
let me say in no uncertain terms
governor whitmer
her policies have directly led to untold
deaths
of michigan seniors thousands and you
have been
at worst deliberately misled and at best
deliberately misled about those numbers
and that's why are going to be calling
upon the governor of michigan here
regardless of where you line up
to release the whitmer death toll that's
what you're
looking for
and you know i know there's some people
here in protest and here's something
i know okay we're telling a few jokes
we're having fun at the governor's
expense which isn't that hard
here's the deal we often hear this this
term common ground
well you know what i don't care if
you're far left or far right if you're
to the right of a tail behind if you're
the
or somewhere in between the only common
ground that we can find it's not found
on being a centrist
it's not found in centrism it's found in
truth
and so i do hope that even if you may
not agree with some of the conclusions
today
whether you think that this state should
be locked down in perpetuity or the
country should be locked down in
perpetuity
or do you think that people should be
free to make their own decisions and to
continue
making their livelihoods it all starts
with
having the truth available and michigan
has not had that it's time for the truth
to be available that's awesome
i'm sorry i have these slides with me
because i don't usually i don't use
prompter it's not really my thing i wish
i could pull up
joe biden and just have it in front of
me going by rope
something else too i think is really
important for people who are paying
attention
there's been a narrative set out there
that if you think
that the perpetual lockdowns which have
led to deaths which have led to
increased
uh mental illness which have led to
countless businesses
being shut down that you don't care
about protecting our citizens no no
listen
i will give the benefit to those i
disagree with that they haven't given to
us
i do believe that everybody wants to
protect our most vulnerable
now this is times that people understand
that those in the right
that those in agreement with their
president have been trying
for months systemically to protect our
most vulnerable let me ask you this
if we're talking about protecting our
most vulnerable namely our seniors and
our sick
how does a professional lockdown help
that
we are going about in the exact wrong
way we lock everyone down is it safer
any safer
three months from now for 90 year old
grammar roots 97 year old grammar
to go back out there you don't
quarantine
the healthy and shut down businesses
[Applause]
and that's the exact topic of what we've
done in michigan uh what i am going to
present
is irrefutable you may not agree with
the conclusions we have filed
many petitions for freedom of
information under the form of
information act
uh good for this governor there is no
accountability during the pandemic and
it has just been punted
by five days and then ten days so
there's some numbers that we don't have
access to
but that's where you guys will come in
at the end of this we'll come back to
that so let me bring your attention
first
to the policy here in michigan from
governor whitmer
this is something important because
everyone here we remember we're trying
to flatten the curve
i understand that and i agree with that
and by the way if you guys could wear a
mask today
i encourage you to do so practice social
distancing as you feel safe
great we're not here to make a political
statement on that we are here to look at
the data
the facts the science that have either
been hidden or flat-out denied
by governor whitmer now let me
substantiate that
governor whitmer when the outbreak hit
she refused to transport covid patients
out of nursing homes to protect seniors
as a matter of fact
as far as i know and it's tough to get
this information
michigan is the only state look the
drone hopefully it's
it's not a leftover from the obama air
is it everyone's dumping coverage
michigan is the only state that i know
of people talk about this in new york
and i know that michigan is when you
hear people nationally talk about new
york and they're nursing on policy you
go oh
gosh do you think you have it bad
michigan
not only sent sick coveted patients into
nursing homes and you would think they
were readmitting people who were living
in these senior living homes michigan
sent young
sick patients into senior
[Applause]
[Music]
knowing what we know about the virus
knowing what we know about who is most
vulnerable
you tell me how that's a scientific
approach to send a 20 year old before
[Music]
now this happened when nursing homes
told
governor whitmer that they were not
ready but she refused to listen
to the advice of the known medical
professionals and when i say medical
professionals
i don't mean scientists just sitting on
the board i mean people actually
treating and seeing patients and the
consequences of this governor's action
so melissa samuel is the president of
the ceo of health the health care
association of michigan
and she made it clear that they were not
equipped to deal with this which brings
me
to the next point here many of you know
this the veto
from governor whitmer show me about the
veto
a lot of shouts look
fedex shirt right there we appreciate it
maybe you guys could uh take care of the
votes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm voting for president can you do next
day shipping i don't know
so senior living facilities in michigan
face
such a disaster that there was a
bipartisan bill
presented in michigan and this is
important folks and everyone watching at
home because this is a microcosm of the
united states
with a bipartisan bill both republicans
and democrats have passed your state
house
and senate there were three basic
demands and i would say that these are
sensible demands
others would say that they are nazi
demands
i don't know i'll let you be the judge
three demands don't send sick patients
coping patients in the nursing home
don't send them mentally ill in your
nursing home
and if you're going to send people into
nursing homes who had coveted
make sure they are quarantined in a
separate facility bipartisan bill
democrat republican support made it for
your state legislature
veto from the governor
[Applause]
now this is where it gets a little
tricky because as we were traveling to
the wonderful state of michigan
um we found out that governor whitmer
changed the policy
a little bit in private but what's
interesting is the change isn't really a
change
if you look at her reasoning for having
vetoed that belt
it's the exact same reasoning as to the
official chamber of policy let me read
it for you when she vetoed the bill she
said
the bill was based on the false premise
that isolation units created with
existing facilities are somehow
insufficient to protect seniors okay the
new order
says the new cairn recovery centers must
designate a distinct area for cobin 19
oscillation
they must have a designated wing or
separate unit
hold on a second how is that a change
your feet took the bill because you said
we already had it
a little bit
brought forward because medical
professionals science you know the folks
we all deny apparently said hey hey
we need to protect seniors she said you
don't need to you guys are fine
and now she's instituting a new order
only after we have been behind the
scenes sending requests for information
that have either been denied
or not responded to to the exact same
effect
which brings me to the next point here
the numbers
real numbers yes sir real numbers i
appreciate it
i love the headband i don't know whether
i don't know whether to give you a hug
or jazzercise
so this is one thing we've been told
right how many people here have been
accused of denying science if you say
that you disagree with the lockdowns
yeah now how many people here have
either had a business
or know people who own businesses that
have been irreparably damaged
there you go science deniers okay so
what what's the correlation here as it
relates to coveton states because
michigan has it pretty bad well
you can look at this chart we have
european countries as well as the united
states different states
lockdowns did lockdowns help states no
you can't argue that it helped states
and you can't necessarily argue that it
hurt states i'm not making that argument
what about total population is it only
states with huge populations that were
affected
no is it as the media's been saying now
and they shift and pivot
population density no it's not
population density how about geography
this is where we started digging for
numbers and i tell you what
i thought i had it wrong i had to have
it confirmed by two
three four doctors and people who worked
in running numbers so we can look at
states with similar population densities
and states that either neighbor or
touch michigan we can look at wisconsin
we can look at ohio
we can look at illinois we can look at
indiana we can look i think i already
said ohio but i guess we say them twice
i don't know all right stop it they're
not here
john kasich's not gonna show up running
through the crowd
now these states although they have
similar geographic locations
and very similar population densities do
not have anywhere near the death rates
even more the states that have the
directly comparable population densities
states like north carolina states like
tennessee
not even close so why is michigan
an outlier well this is where we'll
bring you up to the next slide
and that is the verifiable cover-up
i'm not a fan of cover-ups either i
agree with your boo
so this is where it gets really scary
to the point where you have to either
assume incompetence to the level that
someone is unfit for office
or the kind of misleading i hate to use
the word evil but covering up these
numbers when people are suffering and
dying
either way it's unacceptable how many
people here have heard the reported
number
that in michigan 34 of all your deaths
only 34
come from senior living homes show of
hands
that number is a lie and no one else has
been able to dig into this as we have
before and we're still waiting on some
information from the governor which
you'll be filing to when we're done with
this so
um you look at it and you say 34
well you know what that seems to track
with other states let's look at the
other states nearby again those states
were mentioned ohio wisconsin yeah those
states all have give or take
a fatality rate of the total deaths
coming from
senior living homes between 28 to 36
depending on the numbers you use okay so
that would seem to check out
until you take one thing into
consideration this was fine print that i
don't believe i read it m live
michigan's tracking and it's the only
state with these comparable states
doesn't include assisted living
facilities
adult foster care facilities or homes
for the aged
[Applause]
so let me be clear all of these other
states here
their total deaths are 34 when you
include assisted living facilities
nursing homes
adult foster facilities and homes for
the aged
in michigan it's 34 coming exclusively
from some
nursing homes you know how many those
are
1967 deaths coming from
about 440. about 447 nursing homes
now here's the here's the challenge
assisted living facilities
are not licensed in michigan okay and i
don't want to get nerdy here but these
numbers really matter and they scared me
when i read them
assisted living facilities are not
licensed in michigan but they are used
in those total numbers from other states
so we would need them for an apples to
apples comparison
however there is a website where you can
go right now to verify which nursing
homes
adult foster homes and homes for the
aged
are licensed by the state so the total
number 34
of all deaths in michigan come from 440
something
nursing homes how many currently active
licensed facilities are there in
michigan over 10 times that amount folks
there are over 4 400
currently active licensed homes
so let's keep that in the context all
those states that we're talking about
they're including numbers from thousands
of locations and homes for some reason
in michigan
it's only including one-tenth of that
science right all the little science and
highers out there anyone want to buy
that all of these homes nine tenths of
them ninety percent have had
no deaths not one
and that brings us to another slide here
the results
so we've had to do some digging and some
extrapolating right when you don't have
a governor who's transparent enough to
give you the numbers
you have to try and guess the average
death
age of death for someone in michigan
with covet is 77 years old 75 on the low
end
over 70 percent of all deaths from covet
and michigan
come from 70 years old or older
that tracks with the average age of
people in nursing homes when they start
going in folks
this makes it clear why we need these
numbers now like i said i cannot assume
we can't assume anything at this point
but we also can't make an educated
decision can we as to how we need to
move forward as a state
and a country if we don't have the
numbers from these other
three 4 000 facilities how can we know
if a lockdown which has decimated
michigan businesses
is good for this state in this country
release enough can we hear that let's
release the numbers governor whitmer
release the numbers release the numbers
release the numbers release the numbers
release the numbers release the numbers
release the numbers now
governor whitmer when she vetoed the
bill before and then secretly changed it
more recently said well hold on a second
we don't need any of these rules that
would prevent sending young covet
infected patients into nursing homes
because
these nursing homes can handle it all of
these assisted living facility homes
these
senior homes i don't want to say just
nursing homes she said they can handle
it
well they said we can't science doesn't
matter an instance she said no no they
have the oversight
to handle it well how can you make that
claim when if you have children here i
would ask that they maybe don't watch
this next portion because it is
disturbing
how can you claim that we have systems
in place to protect the most vulnerable
when you don't have the kind of
oversight necessary to stop this from
happening
ah
make it open up
[Applause]
we're not there yet folks i'm not here
to call for anyone to be locked up i'm
here to call for the truth
as a starting point can we all agree on
the truth to start off any left folks
right folks
don't we deserve access to the numbers
and the truth
[Applause]
that man norman bledsoe was beaten
ultimately into a depression where he
starved himself to death
by a man named jaden hayden that was the
man beating him
anyone here know well they were in the
same room together
covent people across the country people
who are watching right now in the live
stream
many folks don't know that they think oh
something went wrong no
no that man was placed a known
dangerous offender with a senior citizen
because they have covet
and we're supposed to believe that these
homes were equipped
and wanted to bring in more sick
patients well who could have possibly
seen that coming
says the governor who could have seen it
coming well let me tell you not only the
medical professionals
not only those seeing patients but the
boy's dad who
actually said this he never should have
been housed quarantined with the victim
that he eventually assaulted
that should have never happened someone
dropped the ball
i do think someone dropped the ball and
that someone is governor whitmer it's
time to hold her accountable folks
so now listen i want to go back here
really quickly before i go to what
everyone here can do a call to action to
grammar ruth
your grammar ruth is 97 years old and
she's a firecracker i love her she talks
mad crap when we play
rummy cube she makes up songs about how
bad i am
she accuses me of having a learning
disability because she's from that
generation where it's just okay
but i was just i was with grandma ruth
97 years old
with the house that her husband built
with his bare hands
that's a different generation folks
could i build a house with my bare hand
i mean i could try i wouldn't go on the
second floor
the point is i was sitting outside of
her house
talking with her through a screen door
and she might have let out a cuss word
or two she was a little frustrated but
she would be appalled to know that i
repeat it here and she said
i want to hug my granddaughter she said
who the hell are you
she said who the hell she said people
talk about how it's live your day like
it's its last right live this every day
as though you're dying
live it as though you don't have another
day right and by the way that's usually
horrible advice because you should plan
for tomorrow especially if you're young
you should make sure that you're taking
care of the
those folks that you love but when you
are at that age 97
think about this four five six months
four five six months where she can't
spend time with the people she loves
most and she said hey
i'm 97. i'm willing to make that trade
off if it means that i get to hold my
grandchildren
and kiss my granddaughters
and who the hell are you to tell me that
i can't
now i know that is not popular it'll
fall on deaf ears to those who support
euthanasia
um but whether you agree with that
opinion or not
all of this starts with something very
simple
and we don't have it and that is
demanding the truth
knowing the numbers because we know what
we have is a lie so what can we do
right now folks we've made it very easy
if you go to louderwithcrowder.com
that's our website
one click you can submit your very own
request of information under the freedom
of information act because she can't
deny us all
okay that's a start
and just because if i have to see one
more yard sign in this wonderful state
that thanks the governor for keeping
them safe
[Applause]
we have distributed today thousands of
signs that you can put up in your own
yard
to let everyone know where you line up
and if you weren't able to get one today
again on the website we have made those
files available as pdfs so you can print
your own
give them out to friends pass it on pay
it forward
let's make sure that folks know what
we're talking about now one other thing
that you can do
everyone please show me your phone
everyone here have a phone
one guy's gonna bring out a flip
just a drug dealer with a track phone
okay everyone here has a phone
and what i want you to do is tweet at
governor whitmer tweet it governor
whitmer and use the hashtag
whitmer death toll every single one of
you if you can right now on facebook
on twitter on youtube forward it to
everyone
you can so that we get an answer from
this governor we do not come with a
sword
we come with the power of the pen and
the power of all
our voices this is how change should
come about in america
this is how conservatives bring change
in america
and not a single walgreens has to be
burned to the ground
[Applause]
and i've got to say we do have to get
going here i love this state so much i
i wish that i could be here 100 of the
time it hasn't been the most business
friendly
and your governor gives me the willies
so i spend
a portion of my time here but i look at
a state that at one point was the
epicenter not only of the united states
but the world
and i look at a state that surprised the
hell out of me in the last election
when i saw it get called red
[Applause]
and i saw the media collectively soil
themselves in fear
because they understood as goes michigan
so goes the rest of the country
and michigan at one point was the
heartland of america i know that you
folks
are the heartland and the backbone of
america you made your voices heard in
the last election
right now we need to make our voices
heard to protect the most vulnerable
among us
because they have been systematically
and proactively
eradicated in this state and it has to
stop
and it starts with the truth i'll leave
you with this just recently
governor whitmer said hey this is all
political theater and
we don't need to have independent
quarantining centers because that
wouldn't be scientific but now she's
called
for an investigation into our president
for
mishandling kovit well
listen folks i say this president trump
if you are watching that i and the
people of michigan all would like to say
in unison governor where you want to
conduct that investigation and donald
trump for mishandling coven
all right sweetheart you first michigan
i love you god bless let's make it
[Applause]
happen
thank you guys i got it there's some
security stuff going on
thank you guys god bless bye
love all of you thank you thank you man
god bless love that you have a stogy
i saw some people funneling in
foreign
hey you guys thanks for coming out today
we have the uh over here on the south
side
so if you still need to sign come over
and this thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey thanks for everything bro
[Music]
appreciation
thank you
don't touch me
i'm too lazy to make food
those crowds are gone i think so yeah
took off pretty quick
oh yeah
[Music]
he farming
i'm just kind of standing
and the here
um